however you feel about it on Monday  morning sugar Shawn O'Malley will be  ranked probably in the top two in the  world in the bantamweight division shout  out to Sugar Sean you did it buddy you  did it now was it a Connor Aldo moment  no there's not a Colorado moment because  he didn't just starch him and walk off  after 19 seconds he validated  everybody's kind of questions about  sugar is he Elite can we  bet on this guy can we Bank on this guy  when the going gets rough and it's not  going his way and gets taken down and if  if he gets rocked on the feet how's he  going to respond we've never seen it so  it's hard to bet on that guy well guess  what we've seen it we've seen it we know  when he gets the title shot against  algerman Sterling when the going gets  rough suga's not going to quit I'll bet  on that guy